اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه مقتل خمسه
عمال في انفجار وقع صباح اليوم في مصنع
للصواريخ في منطقه المداغ في العاصمه
انقره الوزاره انها بدات تحقيقا شاملا
لمعرفه ملابسات الانفجار وكانت وسائل
اعلام التركيه قالت ان فرق ليس في نقلت
بعض الجرحى الى المستشفى حاله بعضهم حرجه
وافاد محافظ انقر واسب شاهين بان
المعلومات الاوليه تفيد ان سبب الانفجار
هو تفاعل مواد كيميائيه في المصنع
وفي الخبر العاجل الذي يظهر على شاشاتنا
الان فان
نائب الرئيس التركي يتحدث عن بدء
التحقيقات في هذا الانفجار الذي وقع في
مصنع للصواريخ في العاصمه التركيه
انقر بينما كانت الحصيله تشير الى خمسه
قتله وعدد من المصابين حاله بعضهم حرجا
نتيجه هذا الانفجار الذي تنضم الينا من
امام موقعه
مراسلتنا فرح الزمان شوقي فرح زمان حجم
الاضرار حسب
مشاهداتك هناك ماذا عن الحصيله ايضا وهل
جرى تاكيد الاسباب التي ادت الى الانفجار
مريم بالفعل نحن هنا نقف في اخر نقطه
استطعنا الوصول اليها نقف تحديدا امام
مصنع الصناعات او شركه الصناعات
الميكانيكيه والكيميائيه الخاصه بالصواريخ
والذخائر والتي تعمل على تزويد كل من
وزارتي الدفاع والداخليه بالمنتجات
المطلوبه الزميل المصور لعله يستطيع ان
يريكم اين وقع هذا الانفجار تحديدا وقع
داخل هذه المنطقه صباحا اليوم سمع صوت
انفجار ومن بعدها شوهد ايضا تصاعد دخان
وقال سكان المناطق المحيطه بالمذاه وهي
نستطيع ان نقول انها تبعد عن مركز العاصمه
انقره تقريبا 40 كم لكن سكان المناطق
المحاذيه للمذاق سمعوا هذا الانفجار
بالنسبه للحصيله بحسب والي انقره الذي خرج
قبل تقريبا ساعه او اقل من ساعه من الان
خمسه قتله وتحدث عن انه لم يعد هناك جرحى
بعد ان تبادلت وسائل الاعلام التركيه
انباء تفيد وقوع جرحى باصابات بالغه ما
يعني بان هؤلاء الذين اصيبوا اصابات بالغه
قد قتلوا اثر هذا الانفجار الاسباب مريم
بحسب والي انقره يقول بان التحقيقات
الاوليه تفيد بان ما حصل جاء بسبب تفاعل
كيميائي بين المواد المتفجره في قسم تحضير
الديناميت بمعنى ان هذا الانفجار قد وقع
خلال عمليه تحضير الديناميت في واحده من
الوحدات الموجوده هنا في هذه الشركه مريم
هذا المصنع التابع كما قلت لك
لوزاره الدفاع ويقدم خدماته لوزاره الدفاع
ولوزاره الداخليه يمتد على مساحه اجماليه
كبيره في الحقيقه المساحه الاجماليه
المفتوحه تبلغ تقريبا 700 الف متر مربع
لكن بداخله ايضا
مناطق مغلقه بمعنى انه يوجد هنالك وحدات
متفرقه ومبنيه داخل هذه المساحه المفتوحه
وتبلغ مساحتها تقريبا 200 الف متر مربع
وحين سئل والي انقره عن حجم هذه الخسائر
التي تسبب بها الانفجار وهل كان من الممكن
او من الممكن ان تبدو تبعاته في وحدات
ثانيه قال ان هذا الانفجار وقع في واحده
من الوحدات المغلقه وهي وحده صغيره من حيث
المساحه ومن حيث الحجم وقتل الاشخاص الذين
كانوا متواجدين في داخلها وقال انه لا لا
يوجد تبعات خطيره من هذه الناحيه لكن
التحقيقات مستمره وتم تشكيل لجنه تحقيق
بالفعل تم استدعاء مدعيين عامين اثنين الى
هذا المكان وزير الدفاع ايضا وزير الدفاع
الجديد يشار جولار سياتي الى هنا بحسب بعض
وسائل الاعلام التركيه لكي يدير خليه ازمه
ليعرف الاسباب الدقيقه والحقيقيه لما حصل
يسال البعض هل من ممكن ان يكون هذا الامر
سببه الاهمال مثلا او خطا ما مثلا يقول
البعض بعض الخبراء بحسب تصريحاتهم لوسائل
الاعلام المحليه هنا ان هذا الامر قد يكون
مستبعدا لان معظم من يتواجدون هنا هم
اشخاص
ذو خبره ويعرفون العمل الذين الذي يقومون
به لكن يجب ايضا انتظار نتائج التحقيقات
وانتظار خليه الازمه بحضور وزير الدفاع
التركي وربما مسؤولين اخرين من الحكومه
التركيه مريم فرح الزمن شوقي من امام شركه
الصناعه الميكانيكيه والكيميائيه في انقره
شكرا جزيلا لك